Britney Spears asked her fans to pray
for her eight-year-old niece Maddie such
a heartbreaking story yeah the daughter
of Britney sister jamie-lynn remains
hospitalized as her famous family pulls
together after a horrible accident
Britney Spears has reportedly flown to
Louisiana to be with her family after
her niece Maddie was involved in an
accident on an ATV the eight-year-old is
listed in stable but critical condition
at a New Orleans hospital the details
are frightening according to the police
report Maddie was steering to avoid a
ditch when she drove into a pond Maddie
was trapped and secured by the seatbelt
and the ATVs safety netting Jamie Lee
and her husband Dobin and attempted to
rescue but were unsuccessful first
responders were on the scene within two
minutes and freed her this was Maddie on
her seventh birthday surprised as she
was presented with a brand-new atv a
spears family source tells ET that
maddie is a cautious rider who quote
grew up riding ATVs just like Jamie Lynn
did she's very cautious eg Online's
music editor so Keshia lacy flew to
Louisiana and June to interview Maddie's
mom Jamie Lynn Spears and her husband
Jamie Watson
she'll be eight this weekend this year
it's like she's kind of coming into
wanted to do big-girl things when I was
with Maddie and Jamie Lynn and Louisiana
you could really tell that they were in
an incredibly tight-knit family unit
really there for each other and Maddie
at the time was so sweet and so friendly
to meet TIG Jamie Lynn has been recently
working on a career in country music and
at the Grand Ole Opry she performed a
song called when the lights go out it
was actually inspired by Maddie and the
first night that Maddie ever spent away
from her mom na struggle with
[Music]
Tony but it's really cool to see my mom
on stage because that she's a really
good singer and well she's my mom very
much
won't be the way
horrible and of course our thoughts and
our prayers are with Maddie and the
entire spears family